le professeur chen bonjour madame la
présidente
oui bonjour mes chers collègues je
réitère donc nous poursuivons donc cette
semaine nos travaux dans le cadre donc
du suivi de la crise sanitaire
madame la directrice générale nous vous
sommes donc pleinement reconnaissant
d'avoir répondu à notre invitation
dans les circonstances actuelles vous
aviez vous avez été déjà entendu à
plusieurs reprises au parlement depuis
près d'un an
dès lors l'objet de notre réunion de ce
matin n'est pas de revenir sur cette
période mais plutôt de faire un point
d'actualité sur la crise sanitaire et
bien sûr de tenter de tracer des
perspectives
je vais donc vous donner la parole pour
une dizaine de minutes
la référente de notre commission pour
santé publique france et marie tamarelle
et ensuite nous aurons l'intervention
des représentants des groupes politiques
et les autres députés auront ensuite des
questions à vous poser dans un second
temps il vous sera bien sûr évident que
vous pourrez répondre aux questions des
députés donc vous avez tout de suite la
parole madame la directrice générale la
présidente mesdames et messieurs les
députés je vous remercie tout d'abord
pour cette audition et je voudrais
commencer par vous assurer de la
mobilisation pleine et entière de
l'ensemble des agents de santé publique
france 2 cette situation exceptionnelle
que nous vivons depuis un an nous
retenons une chose ce virus est tenace
et imprévisible et pourtant nous avons
beaucoup appris depuis un an
beaucoup de connaissances scientifiques
ont été accumulés mais comme vous le
savez il n'est pas encore temps de
baisser la garde
comment peut-on décrire la situation
aujourd'hui elle reste complexe et
préoccupante en raison d'une dynamique
épidémique qui est globalement à la
hausse
la circulation du virus est pas un
niveau élevé avec une pression
hospitalière forte en particulier pour
la réanimation dans un contexte de
diffusion croissante de variants plus
transmissible et qui
vienne prédominant en métropole comme
d'ailleurs dans certains territoires
d'outre-mer l'incidence des cas est
ainsi repartie à la hausse la troisième
semaine de février
avec environ + 8% après deux semaines
d'amélioration et une moyenne d'environ
20 à 21 milles cas confirmés chaque jour
le taux d'incidence augmente dans toutes
les classes d'âge entre 15 et 75 ans le
nombre de personnes hospitalisées est
très élevé à la date du 2 mars environ
25000 personnes hospitalisées dans près
de 3600 en réanimation
les tensions hospitalières persiste avec
un nombre de nouvelles hospitalisations
qui elle se stabilise sur la dernière
semaine environ 1400 en revanche les
nouvelles admissions en réanimation
quant à elle progresse 1900 versus 1800
environ 9 % de plus par rapport à la
semaine précédente
cette hausse intervient alors que nous
on nous observons également un excès de
mortalité toutes causes confondues
depuis la fin du mois de septembre 2020
alors parmi les évolutions récentes nous
notons que les personnes de 75 ans et
plus restent fortement touché par le
virus mais nous observons une
amélioration de la majorité des
indicateurs épidémiologique depuis
mi-février dans cette classe d'âge
diminution des nouveaux cas de la
proportion de personnes hospitalisées
par rapport aux autres classes d'âge et
du nombre de cas en est pauvre nous
voyons également que globalement
globalement le taux de mortalité des
revues légèrement à la mi février -5 %
cette amélioration elle témoigne frais
semblablement d'un effet de
l'augmentation progressive de la
couverture vaccinale dans cette classe
d'âge la couverture vaccinale en effet
atteignez 83% pour la première dose chez
les résidents des ehpad le 1er mars donc
une très grande majorité de ces
résidents est par ailleurs globalement
chez les plus de 80 ans la couverture
pour la première dose et de 28% chez les
75 79 ans de 25% à 15 alors que la con
une de vaccination dans les ehpad arrive
à son terme ces signes sont
encourageants témoignent d'une
protection croissante des plus
vulnérables au virus
ces derniers signaux sont donc
encourageants mais depuis janvier de
nouvelles formes de virus sont apparus
qui rendent la situation à certaines
dans son évolution ou moins immédiate
car certains de ces variants sont plus
préoccupants que d'autres et c'est le
cas pour trois d'entre eux l'un qui a
été identifié en décembre sur le royaume
uni
l'un en afrique du sud plus récemment il
a un autre président ces trois variantes
ont la particularité d'être plus
transmissible et du fait qu'ils ont un
impact potentiellement le cours de
l'épidémie nous les qualifions de
variants d'intérêt dé leur
identification
nous avons mis en place un système de
surveillance spécifique grâce au centre
national de référence des infections
respiratoires de l'institut pasteur et
du chu de lyon
et depuis les premiers cas en france
cette surveillance a été renforcé et
repose sur une stratégie globale
la réalisation de tests pcr de criblage
systématique en cas de test positif par
les laboratoires qui permet une
surveillance réactive des variants
d'intérêt connus et aussi l'évaluation
de leur diffusion sur l'ensemble du
territoire d enquête flash qui font
appel au séquençage du génome viral sur
une sélection aléatoire de prélèvement
pcr positive qui répétait à intervalles
réguliers en lien avec toujours le
réseau des centres nationaux de
référence est aussi l' agence nationale
de recherches sur le sida et les
hépatites virales et maladies
infectieuses émergentes et ces enquêtes
ont pour objectif prioritaire de dresser
la cartographie complète des types de
virus que les variants d'intérêt soit
connu ou pas qui circulent en france et
2 permet aussi de détecter l'émergence
de nouveaux variants et enfin
une surveillance épidémiologique
renforcé sur tout le territoire pour
repérer tout signal épidémiologique
précoce par exemple une rousse brutale
de nouveaux cas qui pourrait constituer
également une alerte contenu que ces
nouveaux variants sont plus transmis si
nous sommes donc aujourd'hui en mesure
d'écrire quotidiennement à la
distribution
ces suspicions variant jusqu'au niveau
départemental et ces données seront
prochainement en open data lefa riant
isoline initialement au royaume uni est
devenu aujourd'hui près de 1000 ans et
représente environ 60%
il est testé positif au niveau national
et par ailleurs et on 6% des thèses de
criblage correspondent eux à une
suspicion de un des deux autres variant
les circulations de ces variants est
hétérogène sur tout le territoire
ils ont été détectés dans toutes les
régions avec de fortes disparités selon
les départements
90 départements affichent une proportion
supérieure à 30% de suspicion de
variants isolé initialement au royaume
uni parmi les tests créé blé et dix
départements présentent peu une
proportion supérieure à 10% pour l'un
des deux autres variantes
aujourd'hui et depuis une à deux
semaines
cette augmentation de la circulation des
variants est associé à une élévation du
taux d'incidence en conclusion même si
l'on observe l'impact très probable de
la vaccination et en particulier sur les
plus vulnérables du fait de leur âge
la situation reste préoccupante
l'évolution des indicateurs et de
l'analyse des risques territoriaux dans
les prochains jours les prochaines
semaines seront donc déterminants et
c'est la raison pour laquelle une
surveillance renforcée donc en place en
lien avec nos cellules régionales
les agences régionales de santé unissent
terre d'asante et en support des mesures
de gestion sur l'ensemble du territoire
--avec une attention particulière pour
certains départements
alors au delà de la surveillance de tous
ces indicateurs de nombreuses questions
se posent encore sur les dynamiques de
lucchini est en lien avec nos
partenaires européens en particulier
notre enjeu c'est aussi les investiguer
notamment confrontant les connaissances
théoriques avec la réalité des données
collectées par une question qui nous
occupe par exemple nous savons que donc
lorsque la proportion du variant
augmente dans un territoire il y a
également une augmentation des nouveaux
cas d'infection est ce que cette
corrélation est constante dans le temps
comment est ce qu'elle est influencé par
les mesures prises
c'est un travail d analyse qui intègre
les données quotidiennes et qui fait
également appel à la modélisation
nous nous intéressons fortement à
l'évaluation de l'efficacité vaccinale
vie réelle et en particulier sur les
formes hospitalisés ou sein d'un groupe
de travail européen du centre européen
de prévention des maladies de dc dc avec
des questions par exemple quel niveau
d'efficacité vis à vis des formes graves
en vie réelle dans quels délais après la
première ou la deuxième dose on peut
escompter un impact sur les indicateurs
et la dynamique de l'épidémie
autre sujet que nous investiguons
l'identification précoce des gars de
réinfection donc une affection
c'est la même personne avec deux mois
des cas entre deux tests positifs et
notamment
est-ce que les réflexions peuvent être
associés à certains parents enfin il est
fondamental de renforcer les efforts
collectifs qui ont été menées dans le
cadre de la stratégie qui sont menées
dans la stratégie tester alerté protéger
et le sentais plus de france contribue
également aux réflexions sur la
stratégie de déploiement des tests dans
les écoles en soutien au ministère de
l'éducation nationale et à la définition
de la stratégie des expérimentations
récepteur culturels ou sportifs
enfin donc pour terminer dans ce
contexte les points clés que je souhaite
partager avec vous tout d'abord nous
avons une grande conscience de notre
responsabilités pour rendre
l'information accessible à tous sur
cette épidémie
les chiffres de l'épidémie publié chaque
jour proviennent de nos indicateurs
chaque semaine nous publions des point
épidémiologique à l'échelon national et
aussi à l'échelon régional
ils font le point précis et l'analyse de
la situation et toutes les données sur
lesquelles nous fondons nos analyses
sont aussi sur notre site où on nous
plein datar et en particulier sur la
plateforme chez eux
deuxième point clé toute crise et en
particulier celle ci a un impact sur
d'autres dimensions de la santé c'est
pourquoi l' agence est très attentive à
l'impact que peut avoir
l'épidémie sur d'autres déterminants
tout comme elle s'attache à maintenir
voire renforcer son action pour eux pour
la santé dans sa globalité et ainsi sur
la santé mentale des français nous avons
mis en place dès le début du premier
confinement une eti de répéter
intervalles réguliers les derniers
résultats montrent une augmentation
significative en particulier des états
anxieux et des états dépressifs par
rapport à la vague précédente
et c'est la raison pour laquelle avec
tous nos partenaires sur ce sujet et en
lien avec le ministère de la santé nous
avons renforcé du par les dispositifs de
surveillance et d'autre part les
dispositifs de soutien individualisé et
enfin autre élément d'attention rester
mobilisés contre le coc vide ne doit pas
nous détourner du suivi et de la
prévention des maladies chroniques ou
encore des addictions sur lesquels nous
ont continuellement améliorer les
connaissances et favoriser la prévention
et c'est ce que nous faisons dans le
cadre des programmes de lutte contre le
cancer ou encore en poursuivant nos
actions prévention dans le domaine du
tabac ou de l'alcool
voilà ce que je voulais partager avec
nous nous restons pleinement mobilisés
pour la santé de tous je vous remercie
de votre attention et je suis à votre
disposition pour répondre à vos
questions
merci merci bien que cette présentation
je vais tout de suite passé la parole à
notre référente santé publique
quant à madame marie tamarelle pour cinq
ministres cinq minutes s'est tenue
merci madame la présidente merci madame
la directrice de santé publique france
lui en tant qu une belle référente de
votre institut pour notre commission
voilà j'espère enfin avoir le plaisir
d'aller vous rencontrez au sein même de
votre maison mais d'abord je tiens à
saluer le travail le travail de santé
publique france et de ses 600 agents
voilà qui est mis et évidemment à
l'honneur avec ces temps critiques donc
sacré soit son développement depuis 2016
répond est-ce qu'on aspire en prévention
et promotion de la santé et notamment
une transversalité dans l' expertise que
malheureusement on peine à trouver
encore dans nos politiques de prévention
aujourd'hui la crise ducobu 19 l'a
montré a montré à quel point nous avions
besoin d'un schéma d'intervention rapide
en prévention nécessitant des moyens et
de nouvelles marches de progrès les
français connaissent maintenant son et
public france principalement par les
chiffres qui tombent quotidiennement et
les campagnes de communication sur les
comportements à adopter et c'est à dire
ils le connaissent à travers vos
missions de surveillance et d'actions de
prévention
cessons cette dimension particulière que
je sois qui vous interrogez donc sur les
actions de prévention et de
communication
concrètement et précisément comment et
quand travaillez-vous avec le ministère
des solidarités de la santé et le
service d'information du gouvernement et
vous nouerez expliquer comment vous
travaillez avec les experts venus du
privé comme la bd and enjoy it et aurait
été missionné par le gouvernement et
plus globalement quel regard critique
posez vous sur le nuage de dispositifs
et d'instituts ce plan créé depuis mars
quid de votre expertise de l'expert 6 de
santé publique france dans la
multiplicité de ses acteurs enfin
comment ana
et vous le retentissement sur la
confiance des citoyens
au regard de la cacophonie que ce nuage
de dispositif pourrait laisser
apparaître enfin je mène avec mon
collègue régis juanico une mission sur
la politique de prévention nous aurons
je pense certainement l'occasion de vous
donner de vous additionnez mais nous
venons de faire déjà un point d'étape
avec la cour des comptes qui réinterroge
les conséquences de la pandémie sur les
activités prévention la crise a bien
démontré de l'autre difficulté en termes
de réactivité d'anticipation et
d'acculturation il nous faut une
politique de prévention plus affirmée
efficiente et plus et plusieurs points
interpelle que vous allez d'ailleurs
tout à l'heure souligné les confinements
ont pu accroître certaines addictions
qui trouvent leur origine dans l'
isolement où le stress la cour nous
informe qu'un quart des français déclaré
avoir augmenté
cole cette augmentation des facteurs de
risque pourrait accroître l'incidence
des maladies chroniques dans les années
à venir
avez-vous des données complémentaires
est plus récente
travaillez vous sur ce sujet j'ai pu
entendre que oui enfin sur la
différenciation la déprogrammation des
soins les confinements ont pu amplifier
le renoncement aux soins avec des
retards de dépistage ils n'ont
probablement pas mal été comblés dans
les mois suivants les déconfinement
avez-vous des données là dessus en tout
état de cause autant les effets des
pathologies chroniques sur la montagne
la mortalité durant cette crise que
l'organisation difficile des acteurs de
la prévention notamment des enfants et
des jeunes souligne qu'il a nécessité
d'agir
ce pourquoi nous comptons sur vous je
vous remercie très bien madame tamarelle
vous avez été très concis
je vais passer maintenant la parole
madame annie vidal pour la république en
marche
merci madame la présidente
merci également madame chen pour ce
nouvel éclairage sur le suivi et
l'évolution de la crise sanitaire
vendredi dernier santé publique france a
indiqué qu'elle observait les premiers
effets de la campagne de vaccination
chez les personnes âgées de plus de 75
ans à ce jour 80 % d'entre eux sont des
ont déjà reçu une dose de vaccin et plus
de la moitié sont désormais l'une is et
les indicateurs épidémiologique le taux
d'hospitalisation et la mortalité sur
cette transe tranche d'âge pardon
diminue rapidement en particulier dans
les ehpad ou vos données montrent une
forte baisse des décès ces dernières
semaines
on ne peut que se réjouir que la
campagne de vaccination porte ses fruits
en france
c'est le résultat d'une stratégie de
santé publique mises en oeuvre par des
professionnels de santé dont je salue
une fois de plus l'investissement sans
faille
la montée en puissance de la vaccination
se poursuit protège chaque jour un
nombre croissant de personnes fragiles
particulièrement à risque d'être touché
par des formes graves de lakovic 19 nous
devons cependant rester extrêmement
vigilant car la circulation du virus et
ces variants est importante sur notre
territoire et l'ensemble des indicateurs
restent à un niveau très élevé vous avez
notamment alerté sur le risque de
surcharge des hôpitaux dans les
prochaines semaines certains
établissements de santé parisien dont
l'hôpital lariboisière ont constaté que
les patients hospitalisés dans les
services de réanimation sont de plus en
plus jeunes observez-vous cette tendance
à l'échelle nationale et comment
expliquez vous ce phénomène
quels sont vos projections sur
l'évolution de la situation à l'hôpital
je vous remercie madame merci je passe
la parole maintenant à bernard perrut
pour les républicains
madame la présidente madame la
directrice merci de toutes ces
informations auraient pu briller la
france comptait moins de pros millions
de personnes ayant reçu une première
injection et avec une 6 millions de
personnes entièrement vacciner
pourtant on entend dire qu'au rythme
actuel l'objectif de vacciner l'ensemble
de la population adulte serait atteinte
le 23 juillet 2023
pouvez vous nous confirmer cette
information
la france a actuellement près d'un
million de doses de vaccins non utilisés
nous sommes d'ailleurs l'un des seuls
pays d'europe où la vaccination ralenti
massivement le week-end pourrions nous
améliorer ce dispositif est elle un
ministre et au 2 mars 2021 que 27 % et
25 astrazeneca
par conséquent la campagne de
vaccination est sans doute trop lent qui
rend l'accélérer comment combattez
réticences même chez les soignants de
l'administration du vaccin astrazeneca
l'origine paraît-il d'effets secondaires
quid telle efficacité d eau sérum ou
qu'on crie le variant sud africain du
crâne un virus comment accélérer
madame cette campagne alors que la
menace n'a pas sanitaire qui
s'apparenterait finalement un passeport
vaccinale comporte le risque notamment
de créer une inégalité entre citoyens
qui auraient pu avoir accès au raz de
sein les jours un deuxième question
madame la directrice de gouvernement
rappellent un certain nombre de cabinets
de conseil en stratégie j'ai déjà posé
ces questions bien sûr directeur général
de la santé avec des missions d
attribution mais si on qui sont
importantes concernant la méthode
intergouvernementale les dates de
livraison le circuit logistique ou bien
encore l'ancien de l'amortissement et de
l'accompagnement de la mise en oeuvre du
système d'information de vaccination
l'accompagnement logistique la
distribution des 25 le vide et bien sûr
le recours à ces cabinets de conseil
n'est pas une pratique nouvelle cette
privation la politique de santé appelle
toutefois des interrogations
voyez vous nous parler des contrats qui
ont été passés directement par santé
publique france puisqu'il y avait à la
fois des contrats passés par le
ministère les contrats passés par vous
même madame du tout des du coût des
prestations assurées également justifié
le recours accru à des cabinets privés
dans la conduite des politiques
publiques qui sont au service de
l'intérêt général
pourquoi le gouvernement ne confie t'il
pas plus ses missions à l'administration
et aux fonctionnaires de l'état
nous avons en tout cas pour notre part
député républicain entièrement confiance
bien sûr aux services de santé publique
france au service de notre mieux
ce père et à toutes nos administrations
je vous remercie
merci bien la parole est à madame
michèle de vaucouleurs pour le groupe
modem et démocrate apparenté
merci madame la présidente madame la
directrice merci pour vos propos
liminaire dans lesquelles j'ai déjà
trouvé un certain nombre de réponses aux
questions que je souhaitais vous posez
au nom de mon groupe
quelques questions complémentaires tout
d'abord j'aurais souhaité trop savoir
quand la vaccination dans les ehpad
pourrait être terminée je resterai de
savoir également pourquoi nous
enregistrons en retard dans la
vaccination dans les résidences
autonomie par rapport aux ehpad et si
c'est ce retard pourrait être comblé
rapidement dans quel délai par ailleurs
vous avez bloqué des travaux sur l'airé
infections j'aurais souhaité savoir si
vous pouviez développer vos l'avancement
des travaux sur ce sujet et dernier
point concernant les variants donc
j'aurais souhaité savoir également si en
dehors des variantes connues vous avez
identifié d'autres variantes dans
quelles proportions
et le cas échéant si certains faisaient
l'objet d'une surveillance renforcée de
votre part merci bien la parole et qu'à
madame agnès firmin le bodo pour le
groupe agir ensemble
oui bonjour bonjour madame la directrice
à moi j'ai trois questions la première
question concerne le vaste relevé que
les vaccins et la vaccination dans les
établissements de santé
on voit bien la difficulté d'adhésion
des professionnels de santé à la
vaccination est ce que ce sujet tabou de
la vaccination obligatoire pour le lac
au vide mais aussi pour la grippe ne
doit pas être reposée à l'occasion de
cette de cette campagne de vaccination
ça c'est ma première question ma
collègue a parlé des résidences
autonomie billet je les rejoindrai sur
le fait de comment on peut aller encore
plus vite dans les résidences autonomie
maintenant que 80 % des résidents des
ehpad de son sont vaccinés
mais la question se pose aussi pour les
personnes qui sont à domicile et qui
n'ont aucun moyen de pouvoir aller ni
dans les centres de vaccination je pense
qu'avec peut-être la possibilité pour
les infirmières de vacciner il serait
bon de mettre un plan sur ces personnes
à domicile qui n'ont vraiment aucun
accès à la vaccination même si je sais
que des transports sanitaires sont mises
en place
mais pour certaines personnes c'est
vraiment trop compliqué et enfin moi
j'ai une question qui ne concerne pas la
vaccination mais qui concerne et je les
ai vus dans les hôpitaux la semaine
dernière tous les sujets sur les
pathologies qui n'ont pas été prise en
charge ou sur les diagnostics qui n'ont
pas été fait est-ce que santé publique
france à un observatoire de ces
aggravation de pathologies chroniques ou
alors de ces prise en charge de
pathologies diagnostiqués tardivement
merci merci la parole est père madame
valérie six pour le groupe udi
indépendant oui merci madame la
présidente
en tant que député du nord je souhaite
vous poser une question concernant la
répartition des doses de vaccins entre
les territoires
depuis le lancement de la campagne fin
décembre le département du nord a reçu
près de 130 mille quatre cent soixante
doses de vaccin sur 5 4 millions livré
sur l'ensemble du territoire national
dans le département on a donc reçu en
moyenne une dose pour 19 9 habitants
quant à l'échelle nationale on a pu
compter sur une dose pour 12,5 habitants
cette inégalité est à mettre en face du
contexte sanitaire rencontrés sur notre
territoire car la situation
épidémiologique se tend actuellement
dans la région des hauts de france
quatre départements étant surveillance
renforcée et le taux d'incidence à
dunkerque s'élève à 1039 cas pour 100000
habitants
elle doit être aussi regardé par rapport
à la catégorie des plus de 75 ans
présents en population générale et nous
on n'est pas bloqué plus importante que
dans d'autres territoires
ainsi comme le demande le directeur
général de l'air asu de france au
ministre de la santé et par juste
égalité de traitement nous avons besoin
de plus de doses aux minima pour ne pas
être sous dotées par ailleurs la
recherche avance toujours concernant les
habitants les traitements les chercheurs
de l'institut pasteur de lille ont
notamment identifié une molécule
particulièrement efficace face au virus
cependant les ces cliniques n'a été
rendu possible que par le soutien
du groupe lvmh qui a fait un don de 5
millions d'euros
pouvez vous nous donner des éléments sur
l'état de recherche sur ce sujet et sur
les moyens que l'étape déployés pour la
soutenir
enfin nous avons auditionné le 21
janvier dernier madame laetitia buffet
qui est responsable de la task force
interministériel vaccination que vides
elle nous indiquait que cette task force
constituée était constitué d'une
vingtaine de personnes et qui avait la
compétence de l'approvisionnement la
mise en oeuvre de la stratégie vaccinale
comment s'articulent votre rôle alors
que sur votre site et indiqué que son
thé public achète pour le compte de la
france les vaccins pré réservé par la
commission européenne auprès des
laboratoires pharmaceutiques
je vous remercie merci la parole est à
mme markin bonheur pour le groupe
liberté territoire bonjour madame la
présidente
bonjour madame la directrice générale
chers collègues alors quelques merci
déjà pour tous et ses propos liminaires
et quelques questions qui ont été posées
par mes collègues donc je vais me
concentrer sur d'autres questions a
aujourd'hui j'ai quelques soucis avec
certains chiffres
madame chen nous étions il ya un an au
moment où vous êtes arrivé un an et demi
nous avions discuté de tout le réseau
sentinelles qui existent en france ce
réseau qui avait été mis en place dans
les années 80 et aujourd'hui j'ai un
souci est que ces chiffres parce que ces
médecins sentinelles rapporte rapporte
des chiffres extrêmement faibles par
rapport aux personnes qui plaisent dans
destine clinique en lien avec le
président
ces chiffres sont de 9 pour cent mille
habitants
comment on peut expliquer 7 hectares
entre bien sûr les chiffres qui nous
sont donnés au quotidien qui met plutôt
en évidence les tests positifs et ça
cette réalité clinique
j'aimerais vous entendre sur cette
première question alors mais je remercie
madame tamarelle d'avoir axé son propos
sur la prévention revenir parce qu'on
aurait pu attendre que santé publique
france en effet face énormément de de
campagne mettant en avant le tout
l'intérêt de la vitamine d
près de la population générale puisque
l'académie de médecine avait donné son
avis en date du 22 avril 2020 mettant en
avant l'intérêt de cette vitamine d pour
protéger les risques de contamination et
c'est vrai que santé publique france est
restée particulièrement silencieuse par
rapport à cette vitamine d
comment comment l'expliquer et dernière
question merci pour votre attention et
vous savez qu'en tant que psychiatre je
suis moi même tout à fait attentive aux
effets de la coved sur la santé mentale
de nos concitoyens merci en effet vous
avez évoqué le renforcement des
dispositifs de soutien
est-ce que vous pouvez s'il vous plaît
nous en dire un tout petit peu plus en
terme de moyens mis au delà simplement
du chèque psycho pour les étudiants
quels sont aujourd'hui les moyens mis
même si je sais que demain nous aurons
en commission des affaires sociales une
audition avec notamment franck bellivier
merci beaucoup madame chen merci la
parole d'état jean hugues ratenon pour
la france a soumise mais c'est madame la
présidente madame la directrice générale
la situation sanitaire ne savait est
dégradée à la réunion l' occupation des
lits en réanimation atteint désormais 81
10 poissons nous sommes quasiment
saturation l' agence régionale de santé
à d'ailleurs annoncé hier les quatre
premiers évacuation sanitaire de la
réunion vers la métropole pour ce point
dès demain nous savons tous que la
solidarité sanitaires régionales avec
mayotte joue pleinement
mais aujourd'hui devant l'augmentation
des cas à la réunion avec une dominante
de plus de 53 cents devrions
sud-africain l'inquiétude grandit sur
les personnels soignants mais aussi dans
la population des interventions titre
non urgentes sont déprogrammés
comme un peu partout en france des blocs
opératoires sont fermées ce qui crée une
crise dans la crise concernant si les
voix que évacuations sanitaires elles ne
sont pas sans risques
vous savez c'est un long voyage
idiot 11 heures c'est combien de vols
entre la réunion et l'hexagone
il ya le climat il yal isolement de ces
malades en métropole puisque leurs
familles restent à la réunion nous
risquons d'obtenir le résultat inverse
de ce que l'on recherche la décision la
plus sage aurait été de continuer de
transformer et d'équiper des chambres
supplémentaires ego et d'augmenter le
personnel soignant directement sur le
territoire il faut absolument soigner
les malades dans de bonnes conditions et
à mon sens si la réserve sanitaire n'est
plus disponible en france
si nous avons un déficit de personnel
qualifié
ne faut-il pas faire appel à dissuader
soignants étrangers cubain chinois et
bien sûr pas trop loin de chez nous en
plus par exemple comme cela a été fait
au plus fort de l'épidémie de l'épidémie
dans l'hexagone et aiguilles en guyane
l'année dernière je dis bien à situation
exceptionnelle mesures exceptionnelles
donc ne faut-il pas agir dans ce sens et
soulager ainsi les professionnels de
santé pleinement mobilisés et et dévoué
et pour que les malades rayonner reste à
la réunion pour leur bien et celui de
leur famille je vous remercie pour votre
réponse
merci bien et je passe la parole à
pierre dharréville pour le groupe gdr
merci madame la présidente madame la
directrice générale une salve de
questions et je m'en excuse
d'abord prévoyez-vous déjà un deuxième
tour de vaccination et si oui quand les
dans quelles conditions exactement
notamment pour les personnes les plus
vulnérables
ensuite je voudrais peut-être que vous
éclaire y ait un peu plus le rôle que
vous jouez dans la mise en oeuvre de la
stratégie vaccinale y compris en regard
avec le rôle des cabinets privés qui a
été évoqué par bernard perrut qu'elle
est dans ce cadre là considérez vous les
moyens mis à votre disposition comme
ayant été porté à un nid
vous suffisent ans dans la période avec
la charge de travail qui est la vôtre
des moyens propres 100 ans
quelle est la nature des relations que
vous entretenez avec les laboratoires
considérez vous que les contrats
européens sont suffisants équilibré et
respectés du point de vue de la vaccin
de la vaccination
ensuite vous avez évoqué à la fin de
votre propos les risques sanitaires
autre que celui de la cosi 19 vous
pouvez vous nous en dire un peu plus sur
ce que vous pensez notamment de la prise
en charge des cancers mais aussi par
ailleurs de la santé psychique et
mentale qui semble être un problème qui
grandit de jour en jour avec les des
mesures d'ordre public qui sont prises
pouvez vous nous éclairer un peu plus
sur ces enjeux et enfin dans les enjeux
stratégiques qui vous ont été fixés
d'ici à 2022 j'ai noté qu'il y avait la
volonté de regarder de plus près les
effets des polluants sur la santé et à
ce titre je voudrais vous formulez ici
la proposition qu'en matière de
pollution atmosphérique un enjeu
important pour lequel la france a été
condamnée le territoire dans lequel
vivent autour du golfe de fos puissent
être déclarés territoires pilotes pour
expertiser un peu plus ces enjeux là
merci bien madame la directrice générale
g6 question est ce que vous voulez qu'on
les passe et vous répondait de manière
globale ou vous préférez le faire dans
un deuxième temps elle est avec nous
madame la directrice madame la
directrice général vous avez pas pardon
oui l excuser moi c'est que je voulais
et je voulais savoir
je voulais savoir madame la directrice
générale gsi question débuter si vous
vouliez qu'on les passe dès à présent et
vous donner une réponse globale ou vous
préférez attendre
oui je pense que qu'on joue que je suis
d'accord pour les écouter maintenant
d'accord ok donc je vais leur passé la
parole alors je passe tout de suite la
parole pour deux minutes monsieur didier
martin
merci madame la présidente bonjour
madame la directrice générale plusieurs
reprises cette question a déjà été posée
mais j'y reviens à plusieurs reprises
nos soignants ont été remis à des
programmes et certaines opérations non
urgentes afin de limiter la saturation
des hôpitaux
ce n'est pas un choix facile les
conséquence des reports ne sont pas
neutres pour les patients qui ont une
anxiété qui ont une état de santé qui se
dégrade et finalement on parle de perte
de chance pour certaines pathologies
ce qui est en train de re a bien sûr des
traitements de fond plus lourd et
français par ailleurs ont été moins
nombreux à effectuer leur visite de
contrôle de dépistage ou à procéder au
suivi de leur maladie chronique
ils ont eu peur parfois d'être
contaminés ou de solliciter une
attention médicale que d'autres auraient
eu davantage besoin donc ma question
elle et elle rejoint celle des autres de
ses collègues
avez-vous des données chiffrées
concernant l'impact de la crise
sanitaire sur l'état de santé général de
la population
peut-on prévoir une surmortalité orco
but bien sûr induite par la crise
et puis une question subsidiaire
qu'en est il de la chloroquine parce
qu'on nous l'a vendu dans les médias
comme étant la bonne solution on n'en
parle plus j'entends on revient sur la
vitamine d maintenant je voudrais que
vous nous disiez définitivement si la
chloroquine a été une bonne idée
un traitement utile je vous remercie
très bien je passe la parole à présent à
madame isabelle valentin merci madame la
présidente
merci madame la directrice générale pour
vos propos liminaire donc la gestion de
la cuise a été marquée par un
fonctionnement verticale en décalage
avec les défis bien entendu posés par
cette crise une année après le début de
la crise sanitaire majeure il apparaît
clairement que la territorialisation que
le partenariat au public privé que le
travail médecine de ville et hôpital
école implication
des acteurs locaux dans la réponse
sanitaire est une des clés dans plus de
d'efficacité plus de réactivité et
j'aimerais beaucoup vous entendre sur ce
point ma deuxième question c'est
envisagez vous que cette crypte
envisagez vous que cette crise allait
durer aussi longtemps et que nous
aurions autant donc ombre notamment sur
l'approvisionnement des masques mais
aussi sur l'achat et la livraison des
vaccins est ma troisième question est
plus local nous manquons cruellement de
doses de vaccins l'approvisionnement des
ehpad sur le flux a organisé 20 % de
perte de ces vaccins puisque les ehpad
commandes 5 2 et qu'on leur livre avec
les pharmacies en flacon qui pourrait
délivrer s'il ose vous avez été alerté
par mon hôpital du puy-en-velay sur ce
problème et j'aimerais bien vous
entendre aussi savoir comment est ce que
vous pouvez agir pour limiter ses pertes
de doses merci beaucoup merci
la parole est à marc delattre merci
madame la plaisir ce bonjour madame
heures la directrice générale dé on dit
toujours que les crises passées
finalement instruisent les crises
futures
ça a été le cas en asie avec le strass
il était semble-t-il mieux préparés mais
en europe alors qu'on a connu la
canicule
le hb aena on a toujours l'impression
d'être en retard d'un métro et pourtant
nous avons mis les moyens les
confinements la stratégie éthique de la
vaccination est donc je m'interroge sur
la stratégie scirocco vide puisque avec
un taux aussi élevé en france de 20
milles
on est loin de la stratégie de nouvelle
zélande ou l'australie ou stratégie zéro
co vide ou presque zéro au japon avec un
air en france culture 2 1 si je ne
m'abuse nous portugal à 0,6 en tout cas
vous avez mille fois raison il faut axer
notre nos efforts sur les variantes
d'intérêt notamment de sud africains
qu'ils ont été flashés tapez séances de
qi de l'âge pour non pas arrêter la
vague
je pense que c'est plus pour la ralentir
suite en mettant j'ai mis le paquet sur
les vaccins dont qu'astrazeneca johnson
johnson donc je m'interroge déjà
quand l'on se remet de son médecin
généraliste qui ne sont déjà pas mal
débordé mais aussi les pharmaciens sur
le fait finalement de deux traités
rapidement faire en sorte que deux que
les indications soient au plus grand
nombre parce que la crainte pour la
population c'est comment va-t-on passer
l'été et vu les chiffres qu'on a tous le
nez sur les cheese laisse peu de sorties
publiques france un peu comme le
bulletin météo il faut s'attendre à une
forte épidémie chez les jeunes donc
comment fait-on avec les problèmes
d'approvisionnement qu'il commence à se
résorber dans ma gestion johnson qui va
arriver semble-t-il
et puis lorsque la question finalement
c'est une critique de la stratégie de
santé publique dans cette commune ans
même dans les moyens que l'on a donné de
nombreuses années et des moyens
importants quand on avait au départ des
équipes quittaient pas toujours formés
en nombre suffisant les tests qui au
départ était très long et cette critique
elle remonte à plusieurs dizaines
d'années donc ça c'est la première chose
et puis après comme en santé publique
sans vous inscrire mais dans une
stratégie continentale dans l'europe de
schengen parce que le virus ne connaît
pas de frontières on a vu avec la
moselle des problématiques entre la
france et l'allemagne
donc comment donc vos outils vous
travaillez en synergie avec nos
collègues européens pour l'instant ces
stratégies dans une stratégie
continentale voilà merci je rappelle que
ces deux minutes monsieur divo bazin
merci madame la présidente madame la
directrice générale de santé publique
france vous avez bien voulu nous relater
l'action de santé publique france elle
est essentielle pour mesurer la
circulation de la colite 19 elle est
essentielle pour la décision je voudrais
vous relayez de nombreux questionnements
certains départements ont été placés par
le gouvernement en surveillance
renforcée mais certains choix étonne par
exemple dans mon département de
meurthe-et-moselle
les taux d'incidence et de positivité
sont inférieures aux moyennes nationales
constaté alors même que le taux de
dépistage
il est plus important noté moselle que
la moyenne nationale
comment l'expliquez vous comment
pouvez-vous le justifier cela semble
profondément injuste pour la meurthe et
moselle
si cela aboutit à de nouvelles mesures
liberticides
deuxième question les tests salivaires
vont se développer comment allez-vous
recenser les résultats notamment positif
troisième question vous avez évoqué les
tests de criblage pour mesurer le
développement des variants faites vous
appel à l'ensemble des acteurs publics
et privés dans le territoire pour
participer à ce défi du criblage
quatrième question vous avez expliqué
que certains variants sont davantage
présents dans certains territoires
comment l'expliquez vous et quels
enseignements en tirez-vous
enfin dernière question y at il aussi
des variants français qui serait moins
recherchés car moins dangereux très bien
la parole et d'un bénédicte non je me
trompe pas non c'est sain et c'est moi
bénédicte pétel oui bonjour madame la
directrice générale merci pour votre
intervention votre introduction
merci pour tous les outils les études
quantitatives et qualitatives que l'on
trouve sur votre site et qui permet
d'observer le comportement les les
évolutions de l'épidémie et le
comportement les évolutions des français
moi je voudrais vous alerter sur les
jeunes donc
vous avez parlé de ce mal être
psychologique qui grandit et
particulièrement sur les chez les jeunes
dont les liens sociaux viennent à
manquer en décembre 2020 un rapport
parlementaire menée par mes collègues
sandrine manche et marie george buffet a
souligné les effets délétères du coc
vide et du confinement sur un grand
nombre de jeunes
elle décrivait dans le rapport un jeune
sur six a arrêté ses études 30% ont
renoncé à l'accès aux soins et plus de
50% sont inquiets pour leur santé
mentale
donc face à cette situation des réponses
ont été apportées comme le chèque psy la
réouverture partielle des universités et
je peux témoigner de du plaisir j'ai eu
plusieurs contacts avec des jeunes de
reprendre la fac cette semaine ou la
semaine dernière le plaisir de ces
jeunes mais moi je suis en ile-de-france
et ces jeunes me disent je suis content
de reprendre la fac mais on nous reparle
d'un re confinement partiel et j'ai peur
que du coup on referme nos facultés
donc voilà ma question c'est qu'en est
il de ces jeunes avec cette éventuelle
reconfirme ans et est ce que vous allez
mettre en place d'autres pistes pour
accompagner ces jeunes en difficulté
voilà merci très bien merci
la parole est à monsieur alain ratier
oui bonjour madame la présidente
bonjour madame la directrice générale
merci pour votre exposé bon il ya
beaucoup de questions qui ont déjà été
posées par mes collègues notamment sur
le retard dans la vaccination des
soignants qui m'interroge sur
l'approvisionnement des vaccins sur le
nombre de stocks que l'on détient au
niveau national actuellement sur la
répartition des vaccins ça a été évoqué
par d'autres collègues sur le sur chacun
de nos départements
donc je vais pas refaire une redite moi
je voulais peut-être en complément à
voir est ce que vous avez une vision
aujourd'hui sur les tests salivaires
dans les écoles puisque la rentrée a eu
lieu est-ce qu'on a quelques éléments et
tout à l'heure dans votre exposé vous
avez parlé de tests que
durée les sportifs est-ce que vous
pouvez m'en dire un peu plus merci très
bien donc j'ai deux autres questions qui
se sont rajoutés désolé madame la
directrice
jean louis touraine vous avez la parole
merci même la présidente madame la
directrice générale plusieurs pays
développés notamment en europe ont
intégré massivement alors stratégie de
lutte contre le corps n'a virus l'a
commis 19
plusieurs nouveaux outils et techniques
de dépistage qui ont fait leurs preuves
le séquençage génomique la philo
dynamique et les modélisations
mathématiques
ainsi le danemark utilise le séquençage
pour identifier les chaînes de
transmission les stoppée le plus
rapidement possible et prendre des
mesures appropriées dans ce pays 20% des
tests positifs font l'objet d'un
séquençage contre seulement 0 points 15
% en france d'un après les données de la
base de données de référence gizeh d'
achat qu un c'est que le séquençage est
très utile pour suivre les mutations que
ce soit les variants qui explique un
changement de la dynamique de l'épidémie
où les mutations note
c'est ce qui est baptisé philo dynamie
discipline permettant d'étudier la
structure de l'épidémie on peut par
exemple déterminer s'il ya une épidémie
par département ou si la propagation se
fait plutôt au niveau national dans un
entretien à de conversation samuel à
lisant directeur de recherche au cnrs
pointe le fait qu'en france la
percolation entre recherche publique et
agences de santé publique reste limitée
il indique notamment que santé publique
france ne fait pratiquement par de
modélisations mathématiques ni de philo
dynamie ma question est simple
madame la directrice générale n'est-il
pas urgent d'investir massivement dans
ces outils et techniques
particulièrement utile
merci je prends la toute dernière
question madame jacqueline dubois vous
avez la parole merci madame la
présidente madame la directrice générale
je tenais tout d'abord à souligner
l'importance des travaux réalisés par
santé publique france où notre
connaissance de l'épidémie les
indicateurs sont de plus en plus
élaborées précis
ils sont précieux pour aménager nos
politiques publiques et protéger les
français à court terme des indicateurs
fournis par santé publique france nous
permettent de suivre l'évolution de
l'épidémie sous différents angles
à plus long terme ce suivi d'indicateurs
doit servir à produire et capitaliser
des connaissances sur les répercussions
de la cog hill 19 la santé mentale la
consommation de substances psychoactives
la nutrition l'activité physique
madame la directrice comment le suivi
des dommages collatéraux de cette de
l'épidémie évolue-t-il comment pouvons
nous mieux conjuguer ces deux paramètres
dans le suivi de l'épidémie je pense
notamment aux résidents des ehpad
fragilisé par l'arrêt des visites de
famille je vous remercie
merci bien chers collègues et bien
madame la directrice je vous passe la
parole
suite à ces questions très riche et très
dense en effet nous aurions donc tu veux
je vais tâcher d'essayer de répondre le
plus possible évidemment monde le de la
manière la plus complète possible l
ensemble des questions et je vous fais
confiance à mesdames et messieurs les
députés
la présidente pour me rappeler les
questions et lors de l'évent qui
nécessiterait des réponses que j'aurais
pu ne pas suffisamment abordé les côtes
sur le rôle de santé public français en
particulier la notion de de la
transversalité de santé de votre micro
madame mon micro excusez-moi part de
retard donnez moi je ne sais pas si
c'est donc je reprends le fil 2-2 des
réponses au persil beaucoup pour
l'ensemble de ces questions le donc sans
faute et bel écran c'est en effet un
rôle de
une réponse à la fois de surveillance de
la santé et bien entendu de réponse aux
problèmes de santé de manière
transversale dans un continuum qui
consiste qui consiste à produire des
connaissances scientifiques qu'il faut
deux peuvent justement les réponses vous
avez souligné l'importance des campagnes
de prévention pour nous les campagnes de
prévention s'appuie évidemment en
premier lieu avec les meilleures
connaissances disponibles scientifique
et donc ce rôle transversal dans dans
l'écosystème est évidemment un rôle qui
doit la s'interfacer avec l'ensemble des
acteurs l'ensemble des acteurs à
l'échelon national le retour du et aussi
à l'échelon territorial et c'est
évidemment ce qui est le permet aussi de
connaître et de s'adapter à la situation
territoriale un effort considérable vous
l'avez souligné a été fait en
particulier pour produire des
indicateurs et maintenant qui se décline
à l'échelon le plus fin du territoire et
qui permet donc d'avoir par exemple au
niveau des communautés de communes des
taux d'incidence et de raisonner à adé à
des niveaux très très faim ils sont
aussi disponibles en manière ouverte
dans la plateforme vod chacun peut y
accéder
nous sommes là aussi bien entendu pour
contribuer à l'aide à la à
l'interprétation de ces deux mots ce que
dans dans cet écosystème avait souligné
que la question et en particulier pour
la vaccination de notre de nos
interfaces avec la taskforce ates force
est chargé du pilotage de déploiement de
la stratégie de vaccination qui est une
stratégie évidemment considérable elle
elle qui mobilise l'ensemble des acteurs
et la coordination de l'ensemble des
acteurs nous sommes pas des acteurs qui
donc contribuer de manière quotidienne
et en interaction très fluide avec sept
aces force pour les pour les tâches et
les missions qui nous racontent qu'ils
sont comme vous l'avez souligné à la
fois la construction des indicateurs de
couverture vaccinale est maintenant
d'efficacité vaccinale est aussi la mise
à disposition des informations sur le
site vaccination info service de
référence auquel nous sommes très
attachés de nourrir peu avec les
meilleures informations disponibles
et puis vous l'avez souligné également
pour notre rôle est également dans les
commandes des vaccins qui ont été
négociées à l'échelon européen
et puis la logistique de ces de ces
vaccins vous avez souligné un point
particulier sur la logistique c est ce
que nous disposons de stock les les
vaccins sont à partir du moment où ils
recevront dans l'établissement
pharmaceutique et dans les plateformes
opérationnelles comme ces vaccins sont
orientés extrêmement rapidement dès
qu'ils sont livrés vers les différents
flux et donc leur acheminement vers les
cibles de livraison et d'assurer dans la
semaine ou la semaine et demie au plus
si bien que nous mais bon pas plus de
stock de 2,12 plus plus plus important
que ça et l'ensemble des données
d'ailleurs disponible en open beta sur
data.gouv.fr mais de d'identifier pour
que les trois vaccins actuellement en
disponibles sur le territoire français
les les stocks dans nos plateformes qui
sont donc très très limité sur sur les
contrats vous avez mentionné que nous
avons en effet fait appel
[Musique]
un certain nombre de prestations de
prestations qui sont donc pour
l'établissement pharmaceutique des
prestations logistiques très
opérationnelle s'agit pas de se
substituer à la stratégie mais qui bien
entendu viennent en appui pour
redéployer tout le réseau logistique
c'est une logistique absolument
considérable qui a été mise en oeuvre
vous avez évoqué les menaces que total
ait mignard 9,2 mais ce qu'on est et ont
été commandés près de 2 milliards
distribués pour lever pour la
vaccination évidemment il a été
nécessaire de le redéployer l'ensemble
d'un réseau mais aussi d'assurer
l'ensemble de la simulation et en
transport de flux logistiques importants
et puis il ya un certain nombre de
prestations d'appui technique et en
particulier aux contrôles qualité de
l'ensemble des équipements de protection
également et d'assurance qualité qui ont
été déployés donc pas d'aspect
stratégique mais de l'appui technique et
logistique dans un contexte de
déploiement de geste est considérable je
voulais y revenir
alors vous avez vous avez souligné
plusieurs aspects sur les indicateurs et
peinait musique et sur la situation des
magic à la fois en lien avec un kobe et
david et et d'autres causes aspect je
vais commencer d'abord par donc les
aspects plutôt lié
la médecine et à la part des enfants ou
la copie donc on dispose en effet d'un
grand nombre d'indicateurs d'indicateurs
extrêmement riche à présent et disons
que ce que l'on regarde évidemment en
priorité c'est d'une part les nouveaux
cas et en particulier par catégorie
d'âge vous avez souligné la possibilité
en effet que l'épidémie évolue et c'est
ce que l'on voit aujourd'hui avec un
impact de l'année six nations par
exemple sur les tranches d'âge les plus
âgés donc le nombre de nouveaux cas le
les indicateurs également hospitalier
qui font évidemment fond de l'analyse
sur la pression épidémique dans dans ce
domaine là et qui sont évidemment créé
très important à à suivre de manière
réactive et donc les derniers
indicateurs que nous sommes en mesure de
mettre en open beta concerne les
variants et les dernières données qui
ont été et les données par des points
qui sont maintenant recueillir à la fois
pour les tests de criblage et aussi pour
le séquençage vous avez posé cette
question en particulier
j'y reviendrai donc sur sur les derniers
mots qu'est ce qu'on sait ces variants
sont inévitables mais en fait dans un
virus qui mute autant que le corps d'un
virus et qui est maintenant soumis à une
pression par la vaccination en
particulier mais aussi par un certain
nombre de mesures de gestion
on sait que il va y avoir donc des
gravillons on ne sait pas quand ils
émergent dont on est vraiment très
important de réaliser la surveillance
qui s'organisent en effet avec les
centres nationaux de référence avec
l'ensemble des laboratoires et en
particulier dans les enquêtes flash qui
sont nouvelles et maintenant extrêmement
vont régulièrement
c'est un travail aussi qu'il s'organise
à l'échelon international pour la
construction de ces indicateurs
j'avais souligné qu'il y avait assez peu
donc à l'échelon international on est en
lien avec le centre européen des
maladies avec le ps
évidemment avec l'ensemble des
laboratoires de surveillance c'est vous
allez souligné le fait que la france en
ait fait des pauses encore trop peu de
ces séquences où les séquences qui sont
produites pour pour les variants dans la
base 10 aides en fait ceci vocation à
évoluer maintenant très rapidement le
réseau qui se met en place et en lien
aussi avec l' agence nationale de
recherches sur le sida une maladie
infectieuses émergentes donc la mairesse
et mieux' qui est un réseau commun donc
la mairesse organisant le réseau de
recherche santé publique france en
organisant le système le réseau de
surveillance donc cela répond à la
question de la manière sur ce sujet de
la vente on organise en france en effet
de manière structurée le lien entre la
surveillance et la recherche de manière
structurée et la plus fluide possible
avec des ressources en bioinformatique
qui permettent de collecter ces données
régulièrement aujourd'hui le chaque
semaine après une montée en charge des
premières semaines
c'est plus 4000 séquence qui sont
réalisés qui pour pouvoir donc intégrer
les bases de données y compris
internationale et contribuer à la
surveillance de ces variants et nous
permet d'identifier des nouveaux
évidemment de surveiller les variants
existantes ils sont tout à fait
majoritaire mais aussi les variants que
des variants donc qui sont soit
d'intérêt comme l'e3 que j'ai déjà que
le tout à fait tous identifiés mais
aussi les variants que l'euro
considère comme à suivre comme tous nos
collègues à l'échelon international
parce qu'ils pourraient avoir un impact
potentiel et l'ensemble à la fois de des
enquêtes flash de la séquence génomique
sur des échantillons aléatoires chaque
semaine et à terme ce ne sera pas 4000
est plutôt similaire à 6500 test qui
pourront être faits sur chaque chaque
semaine donc l'idée est bien en effet
d'identifier et de suivre très
précisément l'ensemble de ces variants
d'étudier systématiquement leur impact
potentiel et de continuer à partager
bien entendu l'ensemble de ces données
avec nos collègues européens donc ligne
ce travail très important sur le
séquençage est en lien aussi avec la
recherche et sur la modélisation par
exemple nous travaillons depuis le début
de l'épidémie en lien très étroit et
directe avec à la fois l'institut
pasteur l'équipe de simon cauchemez scdc
des relations que nous avons de très
longue date
et de conclure assez actualise une
régulière et puis évidemment avec
l'équipe de l'inserm au vitoria collins
à ses équipes se réunissent toutes les
semaines et je note effectivement là
l'importance de la film d'une amie et
deux dans le lien avec la et des restes
de la possibilité de développer ces
techniques vous avez souligné le point
sur les décisions vaccinale qui est
évidemment absolument crucial on voit
que dans les ehpad les résidents ont été
très sensibles et ont fait preuve d'
adhésion forte à la vaccination
ce qu'on sait dans les différentes
enquêtes que l'on déploie régulièrement
et en particulier dans cette étude par
vagues que l'on mène depuis la faim
depuis le confinement de puits la
modulant des ponts déploie un module
l'adhésion vaccinale et on voit bien que
l'on peut observer plus l'adhésion
vaccinale après avoir été assez élevé en
juillet 2020 a baissé jusqu'en fin
d'année est à nouveau en augmentation
près de 60% des français déclarent
qu'ils ont il se ferait certainement
très probablement vacciner aujourd'hui
et d'ailleurs c'est cohérent avec
d'autres tout à fait d'autres enquêtes
et on voit également persister un
gradient important avec l'âge n'ont plus
l'âge augmente et et plus il y à une
adhésion vaccinale mais en effet on doit
continuer à faire des efforts
d'information envers l'ensemble de la
population pour améliorer encore
l'adhésion aux taxis dalle qui doit
pouvoir atteindre des niveaux plus
importants afin d'avoir une couverture
vaccinale qui permet une immunité de la
population et de bénéficier pleinement
des effets de la vaccination
heroes il y a aussi des enquêtes qui
sont menées auprès des professionnels de
santé vous avez souligné un certain
nombre de réticences qui peuvent
s'exprimer
néanmoins là aussi on voit que la
tendance dans nos emplettes et en
particulier quels que soient les
professions et en particuliers
professions de santé sont à
l'augmentation de l'adhésion vaccinale
le et donc c'est à point évidemment
important à considérer sur les autres
aspects de vous avez vous avez souligné
que notre notre action également en
termes de prévention dans les campagnes
à la fois pour pour la cofide les
campagnes d'information en particulier
grand public donc les libyens il ya une
coordination sur la communication c'est
très important en période de crise en
particulier c'est très important en
général la communication et que
l'information soit évidemment délivrés
de manière cohérente entre les
différents émetteurs et les différents
secteurs et donc il ya eu une
coordination sur la communication autour
de la queue vide avec une communication
et des collaborations tout à fait fluide
entre le ministère de la santé
le v6 et est aussi l'assurance maladie
et est aussi avec l'évolution d'une du
tome dans la dans la communication qui
est qui et moins martial dirait est de
plus en plus tournée vers une
information qui est un taux de plus en
plus bienveillant il n'était pas
malveillant auparavant bien en tant que
n'étaient plus martial et il est
important aussi d'avoir de mobiliser
dans cette communication le rôle de
l'entourage et de l'action solidaire
envers envers les personnes qui favorise
l'adoption de en particulier des gestes
barrières et de l'ensemble des deux des
comportements qui permet de réduire la
transmission du virus sur le plan de la
prévention vous avez aussi souligné en
effet les expérimentations
les milieux de la culture ou du sport
notre contribution dans donc il ya un
certain des dents dans ce domaine là
qu'elle est dans la réflexion concernant
les expérimentations qui sont à l'étude
donc nous ne venons pas directement il
ya des organismes de recherche aux
particuliers un certain que le chercheur
qui sont impliqué fortement dans ses
expérimentations pour les pâtirait
également les territoires qui sont qui
sont impliqués contribution elle
consiste à fournir l'ensemble des
données disponibles de notre expérience
également et en particulier dans ces
phases qui permettent d'évaluer dans
quelles conditions pourrait ouvrir un
certain nombre de lieux où il ya des
interactions sociales fortes et donc ils
sont des dieux de à risque pour la
transmission du virus sur les autres
aspects en dehors de naco vie dont vous
avez souligné le foie c'est un point qui
qui est assemblé depuis le début de la
crise un point très important a observé
c'est là les conditions santé mentale
des personnes et de la population
générale
pourquoi parce que dans toute crise il y
a un impact sur la santé mentale est
évidemment cette crise ci est
particulièrement importante et puis et
elle est aussi durable vous l'avez vous
l'avez souligné
et donc nos santés bly france depuis
donc la première phase de confinement a
mis en place cette enquête par 20 qui
permet d'identifier et de suivre dans le
temps un certain nombre d'indicateurs
sur les troubles anxieux et dépressifs
aujourd'hui c'est près d'un quart
la population qui se déclare avec des
troubles anxieux et dépressifs donc
c'est en effet des indicateurs
importants
dans l'ensemble du dispositif de
surveillance
on a ajouté et cette semaine seront
publiés à table que sera publié
également un tableau de bord à partir
des données des réseaux de passages aux
urgences venait aussi de sos médecins
sur des indicateurs
donc concernant à la fois les gestes
suicidaires lésiné noir le la proportion
de passages aux urgences pour ces causes
là qui sont ensuite hospitalisé qui sont
déclinées par âge et qui permettent de
suivre en particulier par comparaison
aux années précédentes c'est même les
indicateurs donc on peut on peut
observer en effet que quelles que soient
les conditions de vie sentimentale en
effet exprimé comme avec des indicateurs
qui sont dégradées pour sa santé et en
mettant en évidence en effet bay
souligné un certain nombre de
populations les plus jeunes
évidemment mais aussi d'autres tranches
d'âge en particulier les 25 34 ans
anxieux et puis leur sang des personnes
vulnérables et ce sont dans des
situations de précarité mais certains
troubles concerne l'ensemble des
tranches d'âge sur eux sur les
dispositifs donc la réflexion en effert
sur la santé mentale est à la fois
d'améliorer la connaissance de la
population sur les troubles et les
symptômes qui sont associés est aussi
d'améliorer l'ensemble des dispositifs
qui existent et vers lesquelles ces
personnes peuvent être orientés par
exemple fil santé jeunes par exemple
seacom qui sont décrites que dans les
enquêtes que l'on mène finalement on se
rend compte que les
les personnes méconnaissent encore
troupe donc un dispositif et une
campagne est en cours de préparation ou
pour améliorer ses connaissances là et
pour surveiller la renforcer évidemment
l'ensemble de ces aspects pions fin vous
avez vous avez souligné l'importance de
mesurer l'impact donc dans nos
programmes aussi avec des indicateurs
sur les autres sur les maladies
chroniques par exemple la survie des
cancers sur laquelle on travaille et
donc la mise au point d'un certain
nombre d'indicateurs de surveillance que
l'on fait actuellement à ceux aux
données hospitalières en particulier
pour mesurer l'impact différentes le
phase de l'épidémie sur les
hospitalisations et éventuellement la
survie dans un appart pour un certains
n'ont jamais voilà jeu en essayant de le
couvrir l'ensemble des questions que
vous avez pu poser merci madame la
directrice générale je ne vais pas vous
libérer j'ai une petite question c'est
madame main véronique amacher qui
souhaiterait vous la poser oui merci
madame ce sera très très courte
est-ce que vous avez des statistiques un
bilan sur les décès à domicile par
locaux vides
donc j'ai pas il ne semble pas avoir
entendu parler si statistiques à ce qu
on a exactement un an veut rester à
domicile liés aux qu'ovide merci à damas
directeur général pour cette question
bien précise et concise
absolument donc effectivement une
question très importante
lll nécessite d'avoir les données de
l'inserm qui codent les causes de décès
en particulier à domicile
donc aujourd'hui nous disposons de
données hospitalières et de données dans
les ehpad et
1 données de l'inserm au mois pour la
première partie de 2020 doit être
disponible dans les prochaines semaines
et évidemment dès que nous pourront en
disposer
elles seront analysées et mise à
disposition
[Musique]
bien entendu de la représentation
nationale et de l'ensemble du public
très bien je pense qu'on a fait le tour
madame est quasi générale n'a répondu à
l'ensemble de vos questions mais je te
colle legs pas d'autres interventions de
dernière minute tout le monde est
satisfait madame michèle de vaucouleurs
oui madame apprécie donc madame la
directrice générale excusez moi seule
distraction matin il ne me semble pas
avoir entendu vos réponses sur le retard
d'un but de vaccination dans les
résidences autonomie et le calendrier
virtuel de rattrapage merci madame la
directrice
oui alors eu effectivement sur cette
question là j'aurais pu préciser que
c'est la thèse force et le ministère de
la santé qui est en charge de la
répartition des doses de vaccins une
mouche argent de la logistique mais en
revanche sur le plan et en particulier
la le déploiement de la stratégie dans
les différents lieux
c'est la task force et le ministre
pourra vous répond merci à bien merci
bien écoutez madame la directrice âgée
une question de martinair oui alors
heureux donc là aussi j'aurais pu
préciser que sur l'évaluation des
différents médicaments est l'heureux
leur mise et les indications des
différents médicaments
c'est l' agence nationale de de santé de
médicaments donc là nsn qui est chargée
d'évaluer les différentes indications et
les pubs d'informations plus précises
sur l'évolution de ce dossier à la nsn
et merci madame 6e oui j'ai pas entendu
la réponse concernant les répartitions
fonction de répartition dans les
départements fortement impacté et
notamment vis-à-vis de la moyenne de dos
qui est donnée au niveau national et par
rapport aux régionales ou département
répartition des vaccins alors à ma
connaissance l'ensemble de cette
répartition est en ligne sur sur
data.gouv.fr et partitions des doses est
de la responsabilité du ministère de la
santé et des missions de la task force
vaccination très bien écoutez madame la
directrice merci merci pour toutes ces
réponses nous nous retrouverons de toute
façon demain demain matin car vous
représentez santé publique france à la
table ronde que nous organisons sur les
conséquences de l'épidémie sur la santé
psychique
ça a été un petit peu évoqué ce matin
mais il en sera beaucoup question demain
donc je vous remercie et je
on vous retrouve demain avec beaucoup
beaucoup de plaisir à venir aussi a
vendu pour nous oui merci beaucoup merci
avant de conclure je je je voudrais
rappeler à mes chers collègues que nos
prochaines réunions donc elles se
tiendront toujours en visioconférence
cet après midi à 15 heures et 17 heures
pour la deuxième partie des auditions
donc de notre rapporteur dominique da
silva préparez donc dans le but de de
préparer de créer une allocation pour
les travailleurs indépendants qui sont
effectivement aussi impactés par par la
crise voilà sur l'allocation des
travailleurs indépendants un sujet aussi
important
voilà je vous remercie et je
donc à très bientôt pour mes collègues à
cet après midi merci merci à voir voilà
le président voir